mr hanky the christmas poo is probably
the world's most disgusting christmas
icon but he's also one of south park's
most recognizable characters
and has become a bonafide symbol of the
holiday season
we're here to explore the history of
this gross but lovable christmas mascot
while it seems like mr hanky the
christmas poo
might just be something that the
reliably wacky gross and crude south
park writing staff
squeezed out the character predates the
series by more than two decades
the sentient singing stool sample was
invented by south park co-creator trey
parker's father
in the early 1970s as parker explained
to variety when i was three years old i
had a bad habit of not flushing the
toilet after i was finished my mother
asked my father to have a little talk
with me about toilet flushing
he told me that if i didn't mr hanky
will come out of the toilet and annoy
you forever
in other tellings parker has recalled
his father being a little more harsh
insinuating that if he failed to flush
his leavings would transform into mr
hanky
who would then come after little trey
and try to straight up kill him
on the one hand this is one of the
grossest ways to traumatize a child into
good behavior
on the other hand it appears to have
worked
mr hanky makes his entrance in the
middle of the first season of south park
but has never become much more than a
minor recurring character
on a richly developed well-populated
series this low-key fate wasn't set in
stone however
show creators trey parker and matt stone
initially had much bigger plans for the
living laughing excrement
with parker recalling on a south park
dvd commentary track
mr hanky was something we wanted to make
even in college when we were making the
south park
shorts we always talked about making a
short with mr hanky
that short film never got made but some
of the plot points were ultimately used
in mr hankey the christmas pooh the 1997
south park episode that introduces the
character
stone explained a scene where the pooh
is revealed to be alive
in the shorts that never got made mr
hanky would have been just a figment of
the imagination of a disturbed young
child
who smears stuff on the walls and claims
his pooh is sentient
the mr hanky that made it to the screen
is just as gross
but at least his maker kyle can be
afforded a little more respect
south park's origins lie in two crudely
animated short cartoons called the
spirit of christmas
that trey parker and matt stone made in
the early 1990s
after seeing the first short in which
jesus fights frosty the snowman
fox network executive brian graydon
commissioned parker and stone to make
another cartoon
he could use as a christmas card after
this parker and stone took a few
meetings about developing an animated
series
rather than pitching adventures with the
four little boys from the spirit of
christmas
parker and stone's initial pitch for a
series was the mr hanky show an animated
series about the life imbued piece of
fecal matter who was the focus of their
unmade short cartoon
stan kyle kenny and cartman would have
been supporting characters with mr
hankey center stage
commenting on life and current events
freedom parker and stone's contact of
fox adamantly
refused to put a show about excrement on
television and so the writers heeded
some advice had been given
and instead developed south park a show
about four kids living in a strange town
the duo found corporate champions in
comedy central where executives
expressly told parker and stone that
they had no problem with mr hanky
and thus some very strange history was
made
mr hanky debuted in the south park
episode entitled
mr hanky the christmas poo first airing
on december 17
1997 it was a monumental watershed
moment in the animated series history
with effects ranging far beyond the mere
introduction of a talking turd
mr hanky the christmas poo is the first
of many christmas episodes in south park
history
and introduces many familiar south park
tunes
including eric cartman's classic number
kyle's mom is a big fat
and of course mr hanky's own christmas
carol style theme song
mr hanky the christmas poo is also the
first ever musical south park episode
predating both the movie
south park bigger longer and uncut and
parker and stone's broadway hit the book
of mormon
additionally mr hanky's arrival
coincides with the introduction of two
other south park characters his very
special episode
marks a debut of troubled kid craig
tucker and that of guidance counselor mr
mackie who attempts to convince kyle
that he isn't really interacting with a
talking christmas poo
in your screwed up little head he's the
only friend you have
the holiday spirit of mr hanky is so
strong that it ends up subverting one of
south park's most famous and popular
early tropes
mr hanky the christmas poo is the first
episode where the frequently killed
kenny
somehow doesn't die talk about
groundbreaking
mr hankey's real world origins are
rooted in trey parker's childhood but in
the universe of the tv series the
character's beginnings are a whole lot
muddier
in fact it's actually never quite
revealed how mr hanky came to be
clues to his origins are spread out over
his occasional appearances
which span two decades they suggest he's
an ancient being of tremendous magical
gifts
in red slay down he visits the ageless
santa claus
and the two appear to be old friends and
while kyle is the first person in south
park to discover mr hanky
when the magical creature pops out of
his toilet chef for some reason
already knows about the friendly piece
of feces mr hanky
is clearly not just some of kyle's ways
sprung to life though if you can't
believe it
that's still about as much as we know mr
henke wasn't always a holiday character
with parker explaining in the south park
dvd commentary
i'd actually been drawing mr hankey
since i was a kid and i've been drawing
him with a little sailor's hat
instead of a christmas hat since
elementary school a remnant of this
nautical mr hankey survives in a piece
of obscure south park ephemera
in the opening title sequence of the
unaided original pilot episode of south
park
mr hanky briefly bounces across the
screen wearing a primitive
version of the hat book ending his time
in south park he dons a sailor hat once
again when he's thrown out of town in a
2018 episode
after establishing mr hanky the
christmas poo as a bit of modern
seasonal storytelling on power the
simpsons
long running treehouse of horror
episodes for halloween south park and
columbia records
capitalize on the popularity of the
character just two years after his debut
in 1999 a couple with a tv special of
the same name
mr hanky's christmas classics hit the
shelves the album features the mr hanky
theme song
and other south park holiday originals
such as merry
christmas as performed by mr garrison
and kyle braflowski's the lonely jew on
christmas
the novelty record proved to be a hit
ranking among the top 40 best-selling
holiday albums of 1999 as reported by
billboard in what must have felt like an
era defining moment
mr hanky's christmas classics ended up
ranking just below a charlie brown
christmas
and a head of a christmas album by
barbra streisand whom south park
depicted as the wicked colossus mecca
streisand in 1998.
prior to south park's debut in 1997
cable tv's most notorious animated
series
was nickelodeon's the ren and stimpy
show created by john christopher lucy it
features the adventures of a rage-prone
chihuahua named ren
and his friend a cat named stimpy in
october 1997 christopher lucy debuted a
web series
that features a character named nutty
the friendly dump
a jovial talking feces log a couple
months later
mr hanky the christmas poo another
jovial talking feces log made his debut
on south park
and chris falusi called foul telling e
online
i got 9 messages on my answering machine
from people who said south park took
like
10 of your ideas and put them in one
episode i suppose it could be a
coincidence everyone likes dump humor
south park co-creator trey parker wrote
an open letter denying that mr hanky was
a ripoff of nerdy the friendly dump
after explaining that mr hanky was the
invention of his father
parker said it is my hope that this
personal letter will put an end to your
attempts to slander me in my poo
the gesture worked although a few days
later chris for lucy expressed the
desire for parker to at the very least
admit that south park was inspired by
ren and stimpy
as south park's modern-day christmas
legend tells viewers mr hanky lives in
toilets and emerges during the holidays
his magical nature is undeniable but
could it be possible that mr hankey has
also made his presence felt in space
after all there is precedence set by the
1964 cult classic
santa claus conquers the martians in
january 2019
nasa engineer kevin m gill tweeted a
picture of the planet jupiter
captured by the juno spacecraft the
previous september and then enhanced
the photo depicts a gigantic oblong
object on the surface of the largest
planet in the solar system
said shape is long brown and very
closely resembles mr hanky the christmas
poo
as gil pointed out as you might realize
this association is somewhat appropriate
as jupiter is after all
a gas giant according to a press release
skills sent to huffpost
mr hanky is the unofficial nickname for
what is technically called a brown barge
or cyclonic region on the planet what's
even stranger the picture of this mr
hanky-esque spot on jupiter
emerged just weeks after south park
broadcast the episode in which the
christmas character is forced into exile
having been thrown off tv mr hanky
apparently decided to take his magic to
another dimension
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
south park christmas
and everything in between are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one